[Music]
[Music]
you
that's how you start a [ __ ]
morning and a respect for the people
went down Orlando my heart will not
always but now it's the Lord
[ __ ] humongous to take over
Monday it's a beautiful [ __ ] day
to be alive
the birds are chirpin disguise a white
blue and my art is open and the American
flag is up and that's the most [ __ ]
important thing about today you bad
[ __ ] uncle Joey and let you
know it's okay get out there sling dick
wear your red white and [ __ ] blue
we're back [ __ ] we're not gonna
let this [ __ ] take this over [ __ ]
these [ __ ] and that [ __ ]
but enough with the chitty-chat him it's
time to hit the reef or a dent
oh [ __ ] let me tell you some I got
pretty [ __ ] up with you guys last
night had to take a nap eat a [ __ ]
pound caking [ __ ] no more that night
pipe [ __ ] afternoon but today's a
different story it's Monday people are
walking around they don't know what's
going on hey you know what's going on
there's a [ __ ] reality you got to
keep your eyes open you got to get ten
[ __ ] pieces and you got to protect
yourself you always gotta keep your
[ __ ] eyes open people I hope you
learn something from this and when the
FBI comes to [ __ ] talk to you after
the [ __ ] first time listen on the web
just put a bag over his [ __ ] head hit
him in the [ __ ] head and dip them off
drop them off in [ __ ] Argentina if I
come talk to you twice it's because
you're [ __ ] up something my baby
that's a completely different [ __ ]
story little [ __ ] Maya senator
something like that
this is uncle Joey coming at you telling
you right now get that pipe don't let
this [ __ ] bring me down smoke clear you
got [ __ ] balls today
that's what I'm talking about you bought
three of wattles are you [ __ ]
mentally prepared for a [ __ ] Monday I
take every day as it comes
Monday's Monday Tuesday's Tuesday
Wednesday's Wednesday whatever the [ __ ]
the order is every dead and a different
[ __ ] goal have read that got a
different [ __ ] system but the most
important thing is you're out there you
never quit you don't give a [ __ ]
no is your [ __ ] best friend because
the one knows you get BAM there's a
[ __ ] yes right around the corner
and then they all got a suckin dick hard
work [ __ ] back in your friends and not
giving a [ __ ] about stupid [ __ ] that's
going on there's a [ __ ] about a birthday
party a [ __ ] - dude look at that I got
meetings today I got a podcast today I
have a little workout - that can't go to
jujitsu but I keep pushing forward you
know Messiah that's all that [ __ ]
matters every day I was right until 3:00
in the [ __ ] one I went to distort
doing him one I guess [ __ ] like how
are you were to get me out just my head
was so [ __ ] I came back to slow
briefly I'm on full I was [ __ ] sleep
I don't give a [ __ ] and four hours leg
before you know why
in a wine
because I give a [ __ ] that's why I'm up
a rocket ain't Apple out for nobody no
more never [ __ ] that [ __ ] they got me in
that trap when I was young I broke out
of bars like [ __ ] sound bud
look at that look at nice I'm ready I'm
prepared for my eyeballs look and a
[ __ ] attention you understand my mind
everything come creeping Paula sleep I'm
looking for [ __ ] perverts abductors
[ __ ] Isis you don't make them how was
that myself
I don't watch this out that's the
[ __ ] Laurel neighborhood I watch
everybody I don't give a [ __ ] I'm
watching the [ __ ] cops
Oh some people get both Esmond zero
right in onion just like that oh I love
this little session with your
[ __ ] in the morning
it gets me vented it gets me ready we
get to smoke as a [ __ ] family and
then we all go out there and we [ __ ]
these [ __ ] in the ass
and look them in the eye angle I told
you so cuz that's the best feeling in
the world when you believe in yourself
but somebody's trying to [ __ ] with you
and you look at me I go [ __ ] probably
back it's like my ex [ __ ] white that
dirty [ __ ]
the Cathy ball in Colorado you did you
know John Ball what Cathy ball and
[ __ ] Lafayette Oh Louisville or
whatever the [ __ ] they live next time
say hey uncle Joey's [ __ ] watching you
don't whine because the church family's
watching so next time you see Cathy ball
or John Ball near the [ __ ] kids tell
uncle Joey's [ __ ] watching you
[ __ ] for the you Colorado
residence time to go to work time to sit
listen I was thinking about I got a
second chance in life I had a beautiful
family had a beautiful daughter you know
what
because I'm still here see they hate
when I was gonna die or end up in prison
go away and they could get away with
what they did them but then I'm gonna
get away with it you don't wanna cuz we
got the [ __ ] Church and the church if
I was auntie you [ __ ] so that's
the names John balsam little [ __ ]
bald-headed skinny [ __ ] dude but I
had a [ __ ] slap cuz he called my
daughter a [ __ ] [ __ ] and [ __ ] his ex
when my [ __ ] ex-wife that miserable
[ __ ] who parades herself as a
very nice person but she's a dirty [ __ ]
guys I had a vest again I found that
some [ __ ] paperwork she's [ __ ]
floors now he got him now that we got
him if my daughter don't want to talk to
me that [ __ ] fine yeah I'm saying I
got that coming but she's not gonna get
away with the room that's what I'm
thinking about last night I was like you
know what I got a press [ __ ] charge of
the war my [ __ ] crime stopper
[ __ ] no of this squad leverage always
remember their formation you don't say
nothing you keep it to yourself
and as Pink Floyd says I'm saying you
find the time and you attack
but I don't attack I attack with my
emotions or what I'm doing every day I
get up I could guess I [ __ ] right
I do something positive she gets [ __ ]
weak there you understand me that's the
way the clucking this the next time you
want to stab something are let him live
give them rope and then like that Bayou
living and knowing that they're still
there that's the [ __ ] torture right
they understand me
torture 101 from yokel [ __ ] Joey Diaz
old school and if that don't work then
you put some of fan in that gas tank and
they [ __ ] stole every eight months
and I mother spoiled you [ __ ] shoot
him with a dotted debt from the cop
I don't know I'm stalling for the kill
just how you should be understand me
it's Monday get your [ __ ] together wash
your [ __ ] shine your shoes you got a
purpose [ __ ] I was living under
a [ __ ] rocket ship man apart 30 years
ago understand me Madden give a [ __ ]
that's not who I am that's not who you
are get the [ __ ] out there smoke some
reefer do some jumping jacks take a
multivitamin
I don't give a [ __ ] what you do you
ain't gonna stop where you're at right
now you have a [ __ ] future I'm saying
if I had a future I'm [ __ ] [ __ ]
if I can do what I'm doing can you
imagine when you can do the family white
people around you
couple Uggs
so go out there sling dick if you're not
doing it for you do for your family
we're living a cold [ __ ] world right
now everything can end in one minute if
every thinking I'm in a minute at least
I knew what I was put on this world
information go out and do your [ __ ]
mission [ __ ] all right now you
got me all [ __ ] fired up now person
up another bow just to cut myself
because I bought a flavor I want a
[ __ ] all over the car Oh
[Applause]
still half a bowl how's that what you
guys to pick up my half of fact but
that's it that's it in that short you
got a mission concept I love you guys
more my life
I have a good day
and always let life come full circle it
always does
and at the end even a gulp even an old
dog like me gets a warm spot on the
[ __ ] sidewalk you bad [ __ ] I
love you see you today at 3 o'clock
we'll be stoned to the gills stars
Gorilla Biscuits whatever the [ __ ] you
want to do I got him heroin on its way
right now something Golden Triangle you
understand me I love you guys stay black
to have a great day
I climbed thicker they didn't come I
might tell our being down here is the
boy they're getting in my might then I
paint up a pair lunar wire
I'll see you [ __ ] later